from The Ohio State University Big Ten
Player of the Year two-time Big Ten
Champion a Rose Bowl champion courtesy
of Old Spice and a man who's made my
last two November's absolutely miserable
he's Dwayne Haskins how are you doing
good good I just figured talk about the
elephant in the room right off the bat
between the two of us you know what I
mean yeah that makes sense to you talk
about it no that's okay I mean I assume
that's one of the the pinnacles of your
playing career was how you performed how
you came into game in the big house and
then finished off Michigan and then and
then finished off your Ohio State career
would you agree with also a quarterback
is their legacy is based off hobby time
these times he beat that team up north
so I'm undefeated so what what happened
that week where where everything began
to obviously click for you a few weeks
before but the entire team playing at
that level we had not seen all year long
which is all a lot of people thought
Michigan might might have a chance to a
win in the horseshoe this past year
Dwayne no we're not to lose at home and
uh the biggest thing I preached all
weekend practices that we needed each
other in order to win this game and that
uh every week and we prepared very
handily very hard for that game and his
lot goes into it and we have a lot of
pride about beating a team of norrison
biggest thing I could do for myself is
just prepare myself in the film room
prepare myself mentally and physically
for this game to go this at the time
when defense in the country you know
they brought a lot of different exotic
blitz packages and a lot of different
fronts and looks like I need to be able
to be prepared for and I did a great job
preparing for that and you know it's a
reason why we score a lot of points what
didn't know what did Orban Meyer and the
rest of the staff school you on that you
uh that you caught fire on this past
year that you're gonna take into the
National Football League Duane oh say
coach they did a great job teaching me
how to prepare as a pro then I will use
that going into my NFL career as far as
getting ready for each game how I study
film how it broke down opponents how I
did my scouting in a as far as who did
what well where I can in fact a defense
and
what I needed to watch on film and
thought I did a great job preparing me
for that and I'll definitely do me great
in the NFL for sure okay and you realize
this that the team up north has a name
right you realize that there's the
school has an actually never word even
though I don't go to home word what if
what if you wind up with the Lions
Dwayne what happens yeah I'll be in
Detroit don't ever say that okay cuz you
know I mean it's it's got a name it's
got a name and there's an N at the end
and there's an issue go and but in
between I mean you just won't say it
really I'm sorry no matter what you tell
me or how you worried I'm not saying
okay all right Wayne Haskins here on the
Rich Eisen show where where do you think
you go obviously nobody knows you
definitely don't know but your heart of
hearts tells you what going into
Thursday night in Nashville oh oh
biggest thing I don't know where I'm
gonna go but I know one thing the team
that's gonna take me is gonna get an
animal and I'm just excited to be able
to be a part of NFL franchise and have
my dreams come true and whether that's
with whatever team takes me it whether
that's New York or or the Broncos or the
Raiders or DC or whatever team takes me
at this point in his process I'm ready
to be a part of a team and get to work
so I'm ready when you mean animal what
do you mean by that Dwayne Haskins what
do you mean there's a tip of our solar
that I've had for a long time and it's a
bigger tip of my shoulder and out more
so than ever but uh you know the biggest
thing that I can if I can say to you
race is that you know I just want to get
get to work and I want to be able to be
a part of a team and uh you know use all
that motivation that I have towards
being the best quarterback in NFL and uh
you know do that well and I'll be able
to motivate my guys and what that's our
play the sport
what's the chip from where'd the chip
come from that's on your shoulder so
just comes from you know not always
being the guy that uh you know got all
the respect and the guy that you know I
still work I work really hard and I
dedicate myself to this game and how I
prepare for it and you know
biggest thing I can do is just keep
getting ready and keep
keep progressing to keep keep working
hard does everything else take care of
itself
what's the strangest question you were
asked to the combine going the strangest
question that I've was asked at the
combine I think it was a psychological
question something about a tree in a in
a in a hook and I forgot what that the
particle is so Wow okay what what what
it was something like something about if
you were if you had a hook and there was
a tree something was a fish I don't know
what the question was I was this I can't
answer the question I was like it's what
you do I mean you had 50 touchdown suits
what you should say I'm passing like I
did in the end zone 50 times right no
that's what I said it says for short I
mean but well look if you would only
come to me you know beforehand I would
have helped you Duane helped you you
know how would I answer that question
what the hell is your problem
I threw 50 touchdown passes what does
this help you help me help you
how's that uh I said that is something
very interesting to see the response was
bad I bet yeah so who was your a
quarterback growing up who did you who
did you emulate Duane Haskins growing up
man it was so many cars I couldn't just
put put one guy of course I was a big
fan of Warren Moon and you know my dad
had me watching Roger Staubach and Troy
Aikman tapes and you probably say Dwayne
you weren't even born yet but I was
watching them and you know of course
McNabb was somebody big enjoy growing up
and of course the Mannings and embrace
and Rogers and guys like that so the
biggest thing that I did was just study
the game and there was nobody that I was
like I want to be like this quarterback
because there was so many great ones and
I just wanted it to be like them so I
studied a lot of fun growing up I don't
know if you're aware
or if you're tuning a lot of the stuff
out of what people are saying but Trent
Dilfer said he looked at your film
Dwayne Haskins and say that you're Tom
Brady ish that you have some Tom Brady
in you did you hear that yeah my dad
told me about that and you know that's
pretty cool to hear that from Trent even
though he he he's known me for a while
and you know when Tilly 11 in high
school and that's somebody I grew up
rooting for going into this season I
watched Tom versus time and I studied
how he prepared how he worked on his
body how he ate how he slept and what he
did to get ready for games and you know
I used that as motivation to be able to
get ready for this season and the to be
considered Tom Brady ish it's pretty
cool to me yeah you know where he went
to school Duane right I did or how you
try to get me to say it it's not coming
out well just I just find it interesting
that you take as a compliment high
compliment and you used as help for you
you turn to the Michigan man you look to
the Michigan man I just find that
interesting that Wolverine guy just turn
the W upside down Duane that's the M
that's all I'm saying it's so close so
what are you doing for Old Spice the all
new fresher collection Duane what do you
got this pressure collection you can get
it at Walmart and it has real benefits
and real ingredients like moisturizer
with shea butter and relaxed
collaborative body wash and you know Old
Spice is giving guys more to love and
because they'd have skin too and a very
big hygiene and to be able to have a
greater smell Mehta so there's a pretty
cool thing to be a partner okay men have
skin too right yeah see I see I'm
helping you Adam reading I'm reading off
their tagline so where where are you
gonna be you're not gonna be in
Nashville of Dwayne where are you gonna
be Thursday night I'm here in Nashville
right now but I will be in DC for the
dress I'll be home with my family I'm
not spending time with them going into
this process and you know looking
forward to Thursday night now look it's
a sit last one for you it's a simple
question it's a simple question and I
know I would answer the same way but why
are your family why are you doing away
from Nashville
being on the stage with everybody for
the draft because um I'm not a meat guy
and for me the biggest thing for me was
to be able to be with my family someone
that has been there with me for the
whole process and be able to spend time
with my mentors and my friends and I
grew up with and of course to be able to
share that moment with him something
that I have will put more pride in will
be able to remember this more with that
and to be able to go to the drafts and
hear my name called because regardless
always hear my name called so it'll be
it'll be it'd be great to be home with
them it's been time with them and you
know I'm looking forward to that to that
phone call and then if you get the phone
call and the team says you guys sit
behind somebody for a year you cool with
that you fine with that yeah I mean I
don't have much of a choice you know but
well the biggest thing I can do is
control what I can control
that's me being the best quarterback
that can be every day day in day out so
you know of course I would love to play
early and that would be something that
I'll be working it to be ready for it
but if the guys here in front of me I'm
gonna do the best I can learn from that
guy in the do the best I can that's to
be ready for my opportunity well you
certainly know about being ready for
opportunities Dwayne I'll be honest with
you when you came trotting on the field
for JT Barrett a couple years ago I
thought this thing's this is a good sign
for my team for that for that team
called Michigan and and and then that
was that that's not how it played out
let's put it that way for sure and then
what you did this past year puts you
right at the top of the board if not the
very top of the quarterback board so
good luck to you Dwayne Haskins and hope
this is the first of many times we get
to chat here on this show thanks for
having you bet that's Dwayne Haskins @d
h underscore simba 7 is that simba is
that the The Lion King is that what
you're talking about right there
oh yes you do it okay so that's what is
that your favorite Disney movie is that
what you mean oh by far the Lion King so
what if they do it so they draft you I
mean you're locked in I mean that would
just be the greatest thing right yeah
you know I'll be pretty cool for sure
okay good join you take care yourself
that's Dwayne Haskins here in the Rich
Eisen show for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on VR live or download
rich eyes and show app